let's continue we will go next to our
caller from let's go to the five one six
area code why not caller from five one
six what's your name where are you
calling from and what's on your mind
today
oh hello give it I'm Harry Chris sake
I'm calling from Long Island New York
State um and I was wondering what's your
take on this tickler talks Kyle kolinsky
and why don't you really agree a whole
lot his approach on bringing progressive
change also known as to justice
Democrats
oh no I I don't disagree with the
progressive change and wait so what was
the first part what do I think about
secular talk oh yeah what's your general
take on calculus D well I I mean Kyle's
a friend of mine and we we are in touch
you know outside of any public forums
directly and regularly I don't really
watch anything so if there's a question
about like a specific topic he covered I
guess you know I'm open to hearing it
but I don't know I I just I'm too busy
between my show and teaching and
speaking engagements and and other stuff
to really watch anything so my
understanding is that Kyle's program is
a progressive show and I like Kyle and
even though we might have disagreements
on particular issues I by and large
think that he's doing a good show now as
far as justice Democrats again I have no
problem whatsoever with the idea of
trying to move any elected position to
the left from where it is from a
practical standpoint and again this
isn't about justice Democrats it's a
much more general thing you have to be
pragmatic consider the circumstances of
any particular election and in a world
of limited resources consider whether it
makes more sense to primary Democrats
that aren't as liberal as you want
versus whether it makes sense to try to
replace some Republicans with Democrats
there's no right answer there's no
blanket right answer I just think that
it's perfectly reasonable and actually a
smart thing to consider that any time
you're thinking about how to invest
resources in elections um yeah it kind
of greep I like I like don't you
we could do both primary both corporate
Democrats and Republicans because what's
the point of getting a Democratic
majority in the House and the Senate if
most Democrats are not just Democrats
you know essentially progressives
I'm going to push for like Medicare for
all free college better infrastructure
and whatnot right ya know your questions
your question is a good one which is why
can't we do both and we sort of can but
again there's a limited amount of money
in volunteer hours that are going to go
into election so if we were in a world
that was not zero-sum where you could
just say well we can do everything
within every campaign we will primary
every Democrat that's not as left-wing
as we want and we will try to take over
every Republican seed sure it's just not
the real world right we do live in a
world of limited financial and and sort
of labor our resources for any
particular election so we have to sort
of operate in the real world does that
make sense
um yeah I guess you're right but it's
like is that also Kyle's take or it see
more optimist that you think and more
like me you know like we're more
optimistic well you're being more
realistic which is nothing wrong with
that but do you think Kyle's take is
more similar to mine I couldn't tell you
you don't buy my census you might know
more than I would what Kyle's take us oh
right
no like I mean essentially the first
armed primary corporate Democrats and in
the general for a US House adore you a
Senate seat because their primary the
Republican isn't that what we could do
order wise like yes you could you
absolutely could yes Henry Harry you got
that's absolutely something that you
could do all right thank you so much for
the call I'm very very much appreciated